What is domestic violence?
There are many types of cases that can be charged under the umbrella of domestic violence.
Sometimes, it's charged as a misdemeanor or a felony...
...depending on the facts of the case and the seriousness of the injuries.
A domestic violence case can be something such as simple battery or aggravated assault,...
...or corporal injury on the spouse,...
...or criminal threats, kidnapping, and even murder.
Assault with a deadly weapon is sometimes charged as a domestic violence crime...
...if it occurs between people who are either closely related to each other,...
...or have a family relationship or who are living together.
Assault with a deadly weapon can be something as simple as someone using their hands in a violent way,...
...or pulling on someone's clothing,...
...or using a benign household object in order to inflict an injury.
Elder abuse and stalking cases are also sometimes seen as domestic violence cases.